[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome to the joni
michaels podcast
thursday
[Music]
what
a great week
for justice for democracy
merrick garland attorney general merrick
garland announces this morning that
there will be federal charges against
four officers
who participated not just in the death
but the fraud of the search warrant and
then the cover-up of the fraud of the
search warrant
and the death of brianna taylor so
looks like justice is ticking to the
root of brianna taylor thanks to no help
of some in
the state
hell
it's been a long time coming
for this justice for the department of
justice to finally reach this conclusion
where they're going to charge for
officers in this case
uh to give rihanna taylor her justice
and the family
maybe some closure here on what happened
as as the death of brianna taylor
the people who need to be held
accountable looks like they may be held
accountable in a federal court now
this is uh very important
in the civil rights
movement very important
but also this is very important
in this idea that the justice department
is not moving on certain issues or will
not take up certain issues merrick
garland to be specific
i i would i would say that most people
doubted that the department of justice
would bring charges against these
officers
more than they doubt rather
there will be charges brought against
the people who attempted the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup
so finally finally finally this morning
we are hearing that
we just this country and brianna
taylor's family
will get justice
for her death
so let's keep the wheels of justice
turning uh there is more uh word about
justice in a different court in the
different country it looks like um the
news is is that um brittany griner
the wnba player who was caught with
a minimal amount of marijuana in a in a
one-hitter in russia accused of
trafficking drugs through a one-hitter
residue on a one-hander jesus christ
this is
i can't even believe we have to talk
about this but it looks like um this
today which would be early this morning
um that
brittany greiner was actually
um
charged i believe are sentenced i
believe i'm not sure the news going on
with her there's been a lot of moving
parts this morning we also have news uh
yeah sentencers to nine years in prison
is the is the headline nine years
for residue in a one-hitter what is this
what is russia america what the [ __ ]
this is absolutely ridiculous um
i i i suppose they're giving her nine
years because they really want the trade
that the white house and the
administration has talked about um
it's just showing up that the view
is now trending um andrew warner is also
trending ander warner is a democrat um
he's the state attorney for hillsborough
county in florida i guess ron desantis
has
um suspended him
the big government dictator down in
florida suspending
a state attorney in hillsborough county
florida accusing him of neglecting his
duty
where warren a democrat
basically told ron desantis to go [ __ ]
himself
about uh enforcing laws uh prohibiting
sex changes for minors or laws
restricting abortion
the the state attorney for hillsborough
county told ron desantis where to go and
where to [ __ ] off to and how many times
and desantis didn't like that
he didn't like dictators don't like to
be challenged authoritarians don't like
to be challenged and that's that's a
thing
that's a thing in more political
corruption news uh wanda
vazquez the former puerto rican governor
apparently was also arrested by the
fbi this morning on corruption charges
early this morning
uh more political news we had a lot of
news today like this is just
it's packed this week is packed full of
news um president barack obama
it is his 64 first birthday brahma
barack obama is 61 happy birthday mr
president
there you go
uh let's see what else do we have this
is crazy um that i even have to say
these words out of a mouth there's gonna
be another c pack
what
there's another cpac in texas
oh for crying out loud they're terrified
they're terrified that democrats are
going to win texas that's what this
tells me
donald trump and the hungarian hitler uh
victor orban
our mango mussolini jesus here in the
united states and the hungarian hitler
victor orron are going to hold hands on
stage
in texas at cpac or some [ __ ] i don't
know i don't know
i don't know
another [ __ ] see how many of these c
packs do we do a month jesus [ __ ] cr
when here's my question about this when
are democrats gonna get off their ass
and realize this [ __ ]
works when when are we gonna do these
these [ __ ] circuses of our own
yeah they're crazy and they got all
kinds of crazy costumes and they do
crazy [ __ ] there
it [ __ ] works it [ __ ] works
regardless of how you want to feel about
it
this kind of nonsense this this
continuing of a circus every single
[ __ ] month
works we should do that [ __ ] why don't
we do that [ __ ]
i'm just saying
i don't know
come up with our own cpac
um
fbi uh director ray is now trending i'm
not sure exactly
um it looks
like let's see it looks like he's being
um
questioned
um
it looks like he is being questioned by
senator whitehouse right now about brett
kavanaugh's um
confirmation process
and the handling of the investigation
sheldon whitehouse you know senator
whitehouse from rhode island is on top
of the supreme court [ __ ] where
they've stolen our supreme court bought
and paid for our supreme court and
fbi director ray
has been answering questions from
senator whitehouse about the
investigation the [ __ ] investigation
the non-existent investigation that they
did into brett kavanaugh
that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] so
um we'll probably go to some of that
video
uh as well it's just a fast moving day
today i know i usually do some kind of
crazy rant where i'm yelling and
screaming the first 30 minutes but
there's just so much news
we also have a great guest today
don't forget that we have a great guest
yesterday we had the political
strategist david benderon today we have
another political strategist don't tell
david i said this but rachel doctor
rachel bittikoffer my favorite political
strategist
i just like the way she drops the f-bomb
that's probably what it is
and she's smart as [ __ ]
sh rachel bittikover is smart as [ __ ]
so rachel bittikoffer is going to join
us hopefully at the top of the hour i
haven't got confirmation from her yet
and we talked about it yesterday but
but we're gonna she's gonna join us at
the top of the next hour
did you guys see we have bonehead of the
week up we also have bonehead of the
week poll out there on twitter don't
forget to follow us on twitter so you
can go
uh vote for bonehead of the week over
there tony michael's pod you can also
vote right here on youtube
right here on youtube
just hit the subscribe button
the poll is there
the polls are open
we're going to be counting votes later
on
it won't take us as long as maricopa
county speaking in news and voting and
counting votes
maricopa county it seems like they're
still
they're still um counting votes
i wonder
i wonder what carrie lake like how
i just i just can't figure out how
they're gonna you know
like
figure out
i won but it's fraud i don't understand
how in the hell
they're really gonna get this
under control
they're real they're really gonna
suppress their own vote here folks
i'm dead serious they're gonna suppress
their own vote
by by making their their supporters
believe that even the republican primary
even the republican primary
are is being rigged now think about this
for a second right think about rigging a
republican primary for one second
if you were gonna rig
a republican primary and by you i mean i
don't know the opposition party
right if you were gonna rig it
you're gonna rig it to where you have
the best chance of winning i mean that's
the whole point of [ __ ] rigging and
stealing a [ __ ] election
is for you to gain power
so is it the democrats who are rigging
the election in arizona or is it the
republicans because in a republican
primary
i would imagine the people who want to
rig the primary
i mean if democrats were going to rig
the primary they wouldn't they would
select the person that barely got two or
three percent that's what i would do i
mean if i was rigging up elections if
i'm george soros say and i'm gonna send
out checks to every single person who
claims to be a democrat and to make sure
to rig up an election
jesus these people
the thoughts that even enter their brain
is even hard i lose iq points trying to
[ __ ] even imagine this [ __ ] but let's
just say
i'm a democrat i'm going to rig the
election in a republican primary in a
state like arizona
why in the [ __ ] would i pick someone
who's got who could even garnish 30 of
the vote in the state i would make sure
to pick someone who no one [ __ ] knows
is the biggest [ __ ] bonehead you
possibly could pick
i mean could barely get two or three
percent in the republican primary why in
the [ __ ] wouldn't i rig it to pick that
person if i'm gonna win i want to
[ __ ] win baby that's what i want if
i'm gonna rig elections i'm not gonna
[ __ ] pick carrie lake
who has who has a significant chance of
winning in some counties [ __ ] that [ __ ]
i'm gonna pick the person has no chance
of winning if i'm gonna rig it the
republican primary that is think about
that if you're a democrat rigging a
republican what the [ __ ] do you care
i mean
to to be quite honest with you
democrats are legally trying to
rig primaries and did in michigan
they got rid of the the anti-trump
republican mayor because they really
think that they can beat
i think his name's gibbs they can beat
gibbs
but they were questioning whether they
could beat mayor and they want that
[ __ ] seat
that's that's that's called um
winning
that's that's what it's called
so that's how you actually like rig
elections like legally
by the opposition's primary and that was
just one a very few primaries that
democrats decided to get involved in
that's outside
their purview
but really is kerry lake and the arizona
republicans accusing democrats of
rigging the primary the republican
primary
or are they accusing republicans because
it really feels like to me
that they're saying republican steal
elections republicans rig elections
which is we we all know is what they
really want
and that that's what they try to do
before and after the election
i mean they're still trying to rig up
the 2020 election with some kind of
[ __ ] delusional boneheaded [ __ ] about
the wisconsin supreme court and
cyber ninjas and
bamboo all kinds of crazy ass [ __ ]
[ __ ]
just crazy nonsense
i mean we even have trump secretary of
state's
candidates that are like i'm just going
to overturn it i'm just going to sign a
proclamation making donald trump the
president and joe biden will have to
pack his [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here
that is not how it works at all just
like
coming up with a bunch of fake state
electors doesn't work either
it doesn't work you can't just you can't
just it
it's not as simple as just stealing an
election they wish it was and frankly we
need to consider legislation that makes
it a hell of a lot harder for these
[ __ ] boneheads to even consider some
of this garbage to even have the
conversation about this [ __ ]
we need to make it entirely impossible
for them to
commit a coup again on our government
it's ours like we were saying with david
bender yesterday this is the government
is us
we are the government it's our
government it's us
there's no more proof than that than
this week
when we watch what happened in kansas
and apparently in kansas 20 percent
i am and i haven't seen the study on
this but i i did
see some numbers someone sang
quoted
20 percent
of the votes
that voted no
to strike down
the ability of the state legislator to
strip away rights from women to their
health care and their bodily autonomy in
kansas 20 of those votes that was the
only thing marked on the ballot the only
[ __ ] thing think about that now that
could be good or bad right i mean i want
to know more information rather i
determine whether it's good or bad
but just on its just on its face that
says for sure
that a hell of a lot of people who don't
give a [ __ ] about any kind of other
politics
do not want the government to [ __ ] with
their [ __ ]
that's all i'm saying that is proof to
me
that's proof to me
that even folks who don't give two shits
about other government they don't care
to vote they don't care to know they
don't want to [ __ ] they don't want to
do a little bit of background to vote
for candidates republican or democrat
that 20 of them are like well i really
don't give a [ __ ] about that other stuff
who's going to be what and where and
what office
but what i do give a [ __ ] is you son
[ __ ] taking my [ __ ] rights
and telling me i can and can't have
health care i can and can't have bodily
autonomy
and there was huge registration
in kansas just to push for that vote
so it tells me
folks that democracy is strong
democracy is not weak liberalism is not
weak it is strong it is the it is the
beacon of strength
that in the worst of times
because as great as this week has been
we still have a situation in this
country where a bunch of [ __ ]
fascists in these states are trying to
take away women's rights
and they're trying to do it more and
more and more
they've taken advantage of the
overturning of roe v wade by this
fascist bought and paid for trump court
but they want more
they want more they want to marry your
children
in tennessee they want to ban math in
florida
they want to ban condoms in oklahoma
jesus christ they're going to start
banning boners everywhere
then these things trumped up white dudes
are really screwed
they're coming after your way of life
they're coming after you
it ain't got nothing to do with your
opposition there
sonny
but the people in kansas the women in
kansas specifically
and the men who support women
and support their rights
said now now
no you can't do that government big
government [ __ ] here nope not gonna
happen
and 20 of them didn't even give a [ __ ]
about the other elections didn't even
give a [ __ ] about the other government
that was on the ballot
that's all they went to vote for was to
tell the the kansas state government
stay the [ __ ] out of my medical
decisions stay the [ __ ] out of it and
they got nothing to do with you
which is important and significant now
again to really break it down to figure
out you know the ins and outs democrat
republican all that [ __ ] you know you're
really gonna have to dive into these
ballots a little more in this this data
a little more but you don't really have
to that's what is so important about
democracy folks that's why i invite you
to come here every single weekday monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific for two full hours on
youtube twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the midas touch
facebook page because here we are not
we are not but one thing is for sure
we are not going to sit here and run
through a bunch of goddamn data
and tell you how how dumb you are if you
don't know these numbers
it's not hard to understand what the
people in kansas want
when you hear there was a shitload of
people that only marked don't [ __ ] with
my medical decisions on the ballot you
don't need to know much more than that
folks you just don't
human nature tells you a lot of [ __ ] and
it's really easy to know it
on its face that's why it's so
frustrating right now that's why you as
a pro-democracy person are so [ __ ]
frustrated
because it's so clear to see some of
these things like how can't these
dummies see this stuff
right how can't they see that trump is a
goddamn criminal how can't they see that
trump and a bunch of his allies tried to
take away our vote our government away
from us
and they're still trying to do it
that's why people are frustrated with
the department of justice because the
the wheels of justice are very slow
but those wheels are big and they will
crush anything that gets underneath them
absolutely obliterate them
so yes that is our frustration
that is our frustration but i invite you
to come here and hear this pro-democracy
message get your strategic outrage
in a certain position that you can go
engage in the ballot and we can save
democracy because i believe that's what
we did
i believe that our show and the midas
touch network specifically
push these issues over the edge
and just because we yell and scream into
microphones
constantly
that's what we have to do we have to
push our message and so do you even you
may not have a microphone but you have a
voice
you have friends you have family you
have community members
people at your church
other parents that go to your children's
school the pta
your support groups your colleagues at
work
the people who check you out at the
grocery store
so have that strategic outrage and
engage in your democracy because that's
what happened in texas
and leave
the wheels of justice
and trust the wheels of justice when we
make the correct decision
in 2020 we had a decision to make
we could either go with the corrupt
fascist who wanted to be dictator and
king in the united states of america or
we go with someone who knows what the
[ __ ] they're doing when it comes to
government
regardless of how he speaks or you know
how old he is whatever whatever [ __ ]
excuses you want to make that are the
reasons why you don't like joe biden
it doesn't matter
we picked the person who was definitely
in the choices that we had way more
[ __ ]
way
more [ __ ] responsible
about government
and it shows it shows
folks crude just dropped below 90
dollars a barrel since russia invaded
ukraine
gas is on its way down but the reason
why it hasn't dropped low enough is
because of [ __ ]
corporate greed
gouging you and republicans want to keep
it that way because they voted against
holding them accountable just like they
voted against veterans healthcare
oh tony there's no difference in the
party [ __ ] you
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
there's definitely a difference and if
you don't know the difference you need
to you need to really pluck your head
out of your ass and realize
that democrats in this country are the
only pro democracy
party
they're the only ones interested in it
at all
if you get someone who who is a staunch
republican who will only vote for
republicans they're a fascist
and fascist the fascists are not
fascists are not
pro-democracy
mark my words
they're not they won't be no [ __ ] way
in hell are they going to be
pro-democracy you go you have that
examples time after time after time in
the headlines just today
when you talk about [ __ ] ron desantis
in florida
because oh you're not you're not going
to enforce my fascist laws where you're
out of here
his unconstitutional fascist laws
and we've said it before florida is the
road map to these fascists
but we can do it it's proof in the
pudding in kansas
that they made a big miscalculation with
row folks for years and decades these
republican politicians have convinced
these boneheads absolute [ __ ]
boneheads
that democrats are evil and they're baby
murderers vote for us we'll get rid of
roe v wade we're not gonna get rid of
roe v wade that's what they felt the
whole time we're not gonna actually get
rid of it
but they had to do a little bit here a
little bit there a little bit here a
little bit there
to prove to them that they were working
to get rid of roe v wade i mean they
just wanted the votes they didn't
actually want to overturn it they just
wanted the f they just wanted these
[ __ ] these [ __ ] delusional sheeps
vote that's all they wanted
that's all they wanted
but but the dog caught the car
and when it bit the wheel the car baby
that dog whip right underneath that
wheel and that's where we're at right
now they didn't realize i can't even
imagine how they didn't realize
that the government the big government
telling someone what they can and can't
do
that americans would put up with that
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] kidding me these are same
boneheads same [ __ ] boneheads that
complained about putting a mask on so
they didn't get people sick
same stupid [ __ ] same sheep
that can't pluck their head out of their
ass
long enough to realize that they're
actually liberals that's right all these
trump supporters in these rural areas i
know him i've seen them i've talked to
them i grew up around them most of the
voters
the voters
are actually liberals they just don't
know it
most voting republicans
are democrats that just don't know
they're democrats
it's the [ __ ] truth
it's the truth
they want
just look just look at the dichotomy of
the 2016 election that's your evidence
donald trump was going to give him the
best health care the freest health care
the greatest health care ever
you mean universal health care donald
trump just didn't say those [ __ ]
words those scary words those scary
democrat evil words he just didn't say
those they bought it hook lines anchor
they bought it they bought it
they bought it
immigration we're gonna build a wall
keep the brown people out jesus christ
joe biden
joe biden because of the law
has to [ __ ] patch up that shitty ass
fence that [ __ ] trump built
because there's gaps in it and it's
causing problems
so he's got to patch up the wall he's
not out there yelling build a wall build
a wall he's just doing the actual thing
that democrats do policy like security
border security the policy of border
security now we can all disagree on
certain policies but he's doing the work
but these people out there who are
voting republican
they're actually they're actually
pro-democracy and the problem isn't and
in the political landscape right now if
you're pro-democracy you're a [ __ ]
democrat that's why that is why 20 of
the people who went and voted and marked
the ballot in kansas to vote no you will
not take my rights away from me
didn't vote on anything else
that's why
that's why because those republican
voters are democrats they're
pro-democracy and they just won't admit
it to themselves
stick around we got a great guest we got
gabe sanchez coming in here just a
minute we have a great guest at the top
of the hour don't forget dr rachel
bittikoffer my favorite political
strategist
is going to be here at the top of the
other gabe sanchez to join us after the
break for the [ __ ] list roundup don't go
anywhere we will be right back
after these messages stick around
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa don't delay and
get your part and blanket today for just
99.99
actual parting's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around
through the break
we love having you here every single
weekend monday through friday news
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
and twitch and simon casting from the
midas touch facebook page
we got a lot of sparklers joining us
this morning
everyone everyone talks about how hell
sp hal sparks is a i i love how
hal's great
and he's got he's got a show on i think
at the same time
on certain days i'm not sure which days
but the sparklers join us here and they
say tony tony tony you got to change
your time because you and hal are at the
same time let me tell you something here
is the most beautiful thing about our
show and i'm not sure about hal's
because i know he's on twitch and
youtube and but i'm not sure like
where and when it's available but here
on the tony michaels podcast what i can
tell you about the facts is that you
should subscribe to our youtube channel
is what you should do and you get all
your friends and your family to
subscribe to the youtube channel because
it doesn't matter when hal and i are on
and even if we're on at the same time
because you can go back and re-watch
that's the beautiful part
is you can re-watch you can watch us
live and i know again i'm sure hal does
replays somewhere
but you can do one or the other
maybe we'll have hal on
uh here soon i had hal on the uh
the january 6 select hearings and i've
talked to hal on stuttering john's
podcast uh speaking of that i'm going to
be on john's show this afternoon
for all those out there want to come
over and and
see me on stuttering john's podcast i've
been so busy i haven't been able to make
it on john's podcast but today this
afternoon i believe i believe the time
don't hold me to this
because the the the the time zone
difference i believe it's going to be
uh pacific time
at like 12 45 or 1 o'clock is when i'll
be on i think john goes live at the at
noon
pacific
pacific time
out on the west coast so i'll be on the
stuttering john pont guest day but i've
talked to hal on there
and i've had hal on um with the january
6 select hearings we had him on a panel
how how can talk almost
as much as me hey well okay
i bet we could have a talk off maybe we
should do that sometime
like where we just like talk and see who
can talk longer without stopping
i mean i i think i think
what do you guys think i i love having
the sparklers here
i love having the sparklers here so
welcome to all the sparklers welcome to
the midas mighty
thank you for joining us every single
weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
live and here's the thing the other
thing you can do
if you don't catch it live is you can go
download it on all your favorite
directories
google spotify apple whatever directory
you download your podcast you can
download the tony michaels podcast
right there and while you're there when
you're in those directions please
please do me a huge favor take a few
minutes and go give us a five star
rating or a rating
give us a review what whatever
each directory is a little different
that's the problem with content nowadays
like we got to put this [ __ ] everywhere
like we got to spread our content like
herpes
because everyone watches their content
it consumes their content a little
different
so as content creators gotta you know
adjust for that
so i try to make it free everywhere
which it is there's no gates to our
content
you can just you can watch on youtube
twitter twitch you can download it on
any any uh podcast directory
but do us a favor show us some support
give us a review and if you liked if
you'd like go to the merch stores we've
got them over at thetonymichaels.com
that also helps us out
uh you can find a a a donation link
there as well
um we're gonna get the super chat back
up here soon i promise we're working on
that we've had some issues
and
we're getting we're getting our appeal
together
so um we're just we're just gathering
evidence for our appeal so one the super
chat up but if you like to um show this
show the show support the podcast
support you can go to
thetonymichaels.com
there there's a support link there
there's also again if you'd like some
[ __ ] merch there and gabe sanchez
merch there's some gabe sanchez merch
there as well and gabe sanchez is going
to be joining us speaking
of my co-host and executive producer
he's going to be joining us he he had
this yeah he he's been working hard on
this bunker as everyone knows everyone
knows he's been working really hard on
this secret deep state soros bunker of
his and you know he's he's got a lot of
noise the guys are working on it hard
this morning outside his window with
jackhammers um so he's got to give him a
little bit of time
to get ready and you know you know he's
got to get his his work clothes off or
something i don't know he'll be joining
us soon and also at the top of the other
rachel bittikoffer will be joining us
but let's do this because we got a lot
of stuff to get to there's a lot of news
there's a lot of tweets to go through
folks so let's go surf the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends start the
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome welcome back to
the tony michaels podcast you've reached
a part of the show where we surf the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends on
the [ __ ] list roundup
we got a lot of stuff but a lot of news
to get to today so let's just get dive
right in let's go to the timeline here
let's see what kind of video we got i
want to show this uh this press
conference real quick uh from merrick
garland uh here it is
uh him announcing this morning that he's
going to bring charges against police
officers in the murder of brianna taylor
let's listen
earlier today i spoke with the family of
briana taylor
this morning they were informed that the
justice department has charged four
current
and former louisville metro police
department officers with federal crimes
related to ms taylor's death
those alleged crimes include civil
rights offenses
unlawful conspiracies
unconstitutional use of force and
obstruction offenses
the four defendants were charged through
two separate indictments and one
information
i'm going to begin today by discussing
the civil rights offenses that stem
from the falsification of a search
warrant
we allege that these offenses resulted
in ms taylor's death
of course a lot of people have known
these facts for a long time
that the the documents were forged
uh to get a warrant and to search
uh
brianna taylor and that's what led to
her death and and then they tried to
cover it up
so a lot of crimes here not only civil
rights grinds but also obstruction
crimes it sounds like for the cover to
cover up and fraud uh federal fraud
crimes you know which is super important
uh i i think i think we're making
headway on some of these things that
people are looking for
when it comes to justice now i wanna
i wanna be very careful here this is um
i hear it looks like we've got there
i guess i don't wanna make these [ __ ]
idiots um
famous we need to know who they are but
these are the police officers which you
know
it is what it is these are two of the
the officers here um who have who have
been charged uh i believe kyle meaney
and joshua james i believe is saying his
last name um they're
uh the current
or former i don't know which um these
two are
the louisville metro police that are
charged
uh federally in this uh briana taylor
case
um which is going to be super important
um
in
when it comes to
the justice here that is hopefully going
to be served quickly and swiftly now the
federal courts work very slowly now
because this is just their indictment
which means they're probably going to be
arraigned sometime today or tomorrow or
possibly the beginning of next week but
it looks like they've uh some some have
been arrested so far which means they
probably either either
actually
self-surrendered which is a lot of times
what happens in a federal case your
lawyer is uh notified that you have
indictments and then you go
self-surrender kind of like peter
navarro
tried to do
but several others tried to do i think
steve bannon self-surrendered for his
contempt charge um so so there is there
is that possibility so as the news goes
this morning if we have it on here we
will try to keep up with now what is
going on in the briana taylor case
um i also want to show you here
some video that i found this morning um
of
josh hawley i don't know if you've seen
this josh did you know that josh huntley
and his wife have a podcast
like this guy's writing a book about
manhood which is laughable
you know at best
but him and his wife have a pi it's the
same wife the picture that you see where
he can't he can't stomach hardly kissing
her so like when their lips touch he's
very
barely can touch the lips but it's it's
funny i don't know what this podcast is
called but it should be called
mansplaining
i i think so
i mean
it looks like she can't get a word in
edgewise on this [ __ ] idiot but let's
listen this is ridiculous but let's
listen i think that this is an
opportunity for believers to really get
serious about fatherhood about promoting
it about calling young men toward it you
know what the [ __ ] does that mean
believers
getting serious about fatherhood
and calling young men to it like what
are you talking about
there's a lot of people out there that
are deads
like what do you think this is and some
of them some of them are okay
some of them are great some of them are
damn good dads
right
maybe that's what he's saying is we need
to call people to be better dads or some
[ __ ]
but are you going to take advice from
this [ __ ] idiot
who who who uses a nazi hand symbol
to enrage
a violent insurrection a cheeto dust
kangaroo coup
and then runs away like a scared little
[ __ ] when they come for him you're
gonna take advice about being a man from
this guy
get the [ __ ] out of here i mean um for
dads currently who have young boys to
talk about the significance the
importance of listen to be to be a man
part of being a man is
that you provide for the people you love
you commit to them you just leave them
on their own you know
again with the projection i don't know
what josh hawley's trying to tell his
wife here i don't know but you know when
we go through this [ __ ] lens when we
look through this [ __ ] lens
a projection with these idiots
it's almo it almost feels like to me
that this this podcast mansplaining here
with josh hawley i don't know what
that's what it's called it feels like
that's what it's called mansplaining
and it feels like just a shitload of
projection what do you think gabe
sanchez do you think this thing feels
like projection this this mansplaining
show i don't know is that what it's
called i don't know what the [ __ ] this
thing's called it
it seems like 100 man's i think any time
that josh hawley opens his mouth before
he's running away
it's mansplaining well maybe maybe this
isn't called maine's way maybe it's um
maybe maybe the title of the podcast is
i would love to kiss my wife maybe
that's what i don't know what it's
called i mean the guy is you know he's
he's giving a peck before he's out the
door you know right he's like
maybe he's not he's already you know
the thought of him leaving is already in
his mind before he even is like hey i
woke up this morning i should kiss my
wife he's like i'm out
i don't well maybe that's maybe that's
what the podcast should be called i'm
out i i just i don't i'm not even gonna
play the rest of this cause we know the
boneheaded [ __ ] that he's gonna say yeah
but i cannot believe i cannot believe
that his wife has to sit there and
listen to his nonsense on a podcast like
i i mean i feel sorry for you sometimes
i have to say here listen to my [ __ ]
but i mean his wife his wife's got to
just be like you want me to do what
right you you want me to sit here and
listen to you
talk to me about how manly you are when
i know you're not like we do
every other [ __ ] night when we sit
here and you're trying to project to me
how manly you are jesus christ
okay okay joshie
uh she's also probably like listen you
can either do the podcast in the garage
or you can go to the home in missouri
that we don't really have and do it
there because i'm not listening to
[ __ ] out here you know by dc right
well it it it is it's it's very it's a
very weird situation yeah that he's that
he's putting well isn't it always that
case for republicans there's always some
weird projection but that's what i'm
saying macho man [ __ ]
maybe maybe that's what he's trying to
do is tell his wife something through
this show because they're always
projecting right yeah maybe it's like a
catholic release and he's like this is
the only time i can see you know he
talks about a moment in which he maybe
had an experience with another man he's
like look i'm opening up i'm telling you
you know right he's being manly he's
like he's like
look
to be a man to be a man the man has to
be manly and the manliest thing for a
man to do is be manly as you possibly
manly can to be a man like what what can
you stop saying that word for 10 [ __ ]
seconds when you're really projecting
that you are such a [ __ ] [ __ ] right
you can't why are you running away from
the people you encouraged well if you if
you continue to use the word man or
manly or whatever it might be like it's
like using very in front of a descriptor
you're like oh man i am very very very
excited it's like okay you're just
excited i get it right
i add the emphasis on your excitement
yeah if everything is very then
everything's nothing right like there is
no there's no actual meaning behind it
anymore because you've overused it
you've abused it
and then you just you know chucked it
and ran well speaking of use and a abuse
this [ __ ] guy yesterday holy [ __ ]
this guy appeared on kirby or enthusiasm
apparently let's watch this is alex
jones
when he finds out that uh his lawyer
[ __ ] around and found out and well his
lawyer [ __ ] around alex jones is
finding out here yeah watch how he finds
out that not only did every single one
of his texts get into the hands of the
plaintiffs but it's possibly going to be
able to be subpoenaed by a lot of other
courts let's watch mr jones
did you know that 12 days ago
12 days ago
your attorneys messed up and sent me an
entire digital copy of your entire cell
phone with every text message you've
sent for the past two years and when
informed
did not take any steps to identify i got
to pause here
do you see his lawyer his lawyer's like
oh [ __ ] me that's what that was yeah
there the lawyer was like oh you know i
didn't i thought i did a control f
for sandy hook
turns out i did a control a
and a download my bad
this is like this is like when you have
a sock puppet account on twitter right
right and you're trying to send out a
tweet from your sock puppet and you
accidentally put that [ __ ] on your main
account i've never mean you mean like
you're a politician who pretends to be a
gay i think was black man but turns out
that it's your sock puppet account and
you're actually a white politician
yes yes that sounds so familiar tonight
right i mean i've never done it i know i
don't have sock buppet accounts right i
don't have them
prove me wrong i don't have soccer
accounts but i'm just saying that
there's a good example there but this
guy is really [ __ ] nervous he's
really nervous but let's watch what's
let's watch the look on alex jones
face when he realizes that he
is [ __ ]
as privileged or protected in any way
and as of two days ago it fell free and
clear into my possession and that is how
i know he lied to me
oh
i don't know who put this uh curb your
enthusiasm together but uh i don't know
it's actually from the show curb your uh
defamation curse your curve oh okay
excuse me this is this is just a spinner
yeah this is jones starring in curb your
defamation i i see it
but there's actually i don't know if you
i don't know if you read about this but
there's actually an update so you know
yesterday on the show before the rolling
stone uh before rolling stone came out
with the article that said that the j6
january 6 committee had subpoenaed these
records we were talking i was like i
wouldn't be surprised if over two years
which also be realized it was a
three-year period that these texts and
emails came from
i was saying i was like i wouldn't be
surprised if the january 6 like if
there's something from january 6 on
there
now it's revealed that the lawyer the
sandy hook lawyer has
has told uh reporters uh with rolling
stone that there are intimate messages
with roger stone aka whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa wait a second wait a
second
intimate messages what are you trying
are you is this like sexting or is this
i don't know i'm just saying i mean like
well they're they're seditious sex oh oh
it's it's uh yeah yeah it's seditious
sexting i see i don't know like roger
stone is like sending him sending him
images of his nixon back tattoo or
something or i didn't know what the you
know i don't know if he's sending back
tats or you know demon dick pics or
whatever you know
oh stodger roan he he is such a vital
part in the january 6 uh story and i i
actually think that rhonda stone star
jerome excuse me yeah
we'll we'll refer to him as star jarone
here on the tony michael's podcast
dodger roane is actually one of the back
channels possibly uh there could be more
but he's probably one of the back
channels
to donald trump from stuart rhodes the
oath keeper because and we said it many
times before but just so people know
that during january 6
um the the security detail was switched
from the proud boys to the oath keepers
and it happened after a meeting right
that enrique tario the leader of the
proud boys and stuart rose the founder
and leader of the oath keepers met the
night before in a parking garage which
that that meeting was
totally not shady right not at all and
so what you're telling me is what you're
saying
is that there is evidence that that the
the attorney
of the plaintiffs of sandy hook
you're telling me he's saying in front
of a microphone that
that stodger roane and alex jones have
contact information on his text messages
about january 6th
you know that's kind of funny because
alex jones was also there
yeah you know who else kind of has a
back channel to donald trump and who
donald trump has been on his show
several times do you know who not my
show but do you know
alex jones alex jones you know who else
is really good friends and we have found
this out in interviews of people who
personally know because stuart rhodes is
their father and their and their
ex-husband
that
did you know that stewart rhodes slept
on alex jones's couch did you know that
i did the founder of the oath keepers
yeah so wait a second because this seems
you know juicy to me
this news that you're dropping i mean
that's not uh there's more there's more
to this oh let's let's hear more of the
story gabe let's hear so
it turns out that uh the attorney uh for
alex jones which is the um
f and dino reynold
you know the one who was like sitting
there like this in the video where he's
like oh [ __ ] he's crazy now he's got two
attorneys right yeah yeah but this one's
the main one
right this is this is the one that
actually pushed the wrong button to send
right exactly he was like send it and
it's like no
so you know whether it was intentional
or not who knows
um
but
it turns out that this morning he tried
to file for an emergency motion to
protect the contents uh there's a clip
of it uh i will find for you
so you're saying so what you're saying
is alex jones attorney who accidentally
sent this and then never followed up on
the request to make it evidence um
attempted
to
get
get it fixed by calling for a mistrial
and uh
the reason why the reason why is because
there's probably
way way yeah way more consequences that
are waiting for alex jones on the area
there is very damning information in
those text messages and emails which by
the way those emails
contain child porn
you were just breaking news all right in
addition to that i think alex jones said
on his show he would he would give a
million dollar reward for anyone who
could identify
who put those child porn images
into those emails wait a second wait a
second wait a second wait a second what
is it he said this after after we
watched him
yeah this was another okay yeah this is
he had he had the attorney on and
another uh
this is another crazy sideline story he
goes through he goes through and says
like oh this is malware it was no one on
here you know
and the attorney says oh the fbi has
dismissed any any cons like any concern
that it was uh uh alex jones or anyone
of part of the infowars team now that's
that's the lawyer now keep that in mind
right the fbi has not commented on this
nor why would they right now if they're
investigating
but what ends up happening is the lawyer
says there's no crime we've been cleared
of all charges
that's just a lawyer okay the fbi is
investigating they find porn on there it
comes up because of this trial
this whole thing is crazy man
well it is alex jones right it is alex
jones now here this is from this morning
how long ago is this from just just uh
just a little bit ago yeah
i don't want to see a couple hours ago
so i would say an hour an hour ago this
clip was pulled we can't see uh if the
jury is in the room or not but standing
up you see here was the guy who had his
uh finger in his ass i mean now this is
jones's lawyer
and dino reynold okay and of course his
other lawyers sitting here but this is
the planktive's attorney yesterday that
really dropped the bomb on alex jones
that he had [ __ ] around and now he was
gonna find out um but let's let's listen
to this clip here
you didn't tell me if you really are
trying to move from this trial if that
was just a problem no we we are in from
the show it's like the 17th time or
something
first off first off this judge
this judge absolutely cannot stand alex
jones and his legal team can't stand
them and i've gotten this comment like
oh the judge has no power and that she
doesn't have the power to tell alex
jones he can't lie like i've had all
these alex jones
these infowars [ __ ] idiots in the
comments well i'm serious that we posted
that video of her saying treat him like
a six-year-old child like alex you
cannot lie you can't tell a bleep yeah
why i know it's a [ __ ] lie you're
under oath you cannot lie under oath i
will hold you in contempt well of course
she doesn't want to hold him in contempt
because what we said yesterday she wants
this to play out the judge so for anyone
it might be hard for people to hear
but basically for anyone listening or
watching right now the
alex jones attorney says i would like to
call for a mistrial right
and the judge says well i don't i i
don't know this part but she basically
says like
uh is this in relation to yesterday's
exchange between
um
uh the sandy hook lawyer and alex jones
about the text and he goes yes well you
know there's communication that's going
on between them
um you know and i don't think that's
fair essentially and she's like let's i
turn the volume up let's
try to let's back it up and let's let's
see if we can hear it this time
you didn't tell me you really are trying
to move from this travel if that was
just a little bit no we we are learning
from the show it's like the 17th time or
something
um
based on
just the exchange between mr ranks and
mr jones yesterday
and the
obviously mr benson has been looting
around
the attorney prior to the
attorney client communications i think
that overstates
first of all you and mr mason have been
here with me
what feels like 24 hours a day for two
weeks so i don't know how he has been
doing any of that
number one and number two
it sounds like an enormous quantity of
material
the only thing i've seen is one email i
mean text excuse me one tense so i don't
know what
organization this material is in i don't
know if it's labeled
or if you did a search i don't know and
you don't know
whether he's seen anything attorney
clinic privileged or not so i don't
think you should say that as if it were
established
um
i'm going to deny the motion
so yeah by by the way i'm going to deny
your emotion and you can stick it
straight up your yeah
yeah yeah go [ __ ] yourself so basically
yeah so for anyone who couldn't hear the
context goes like this oh my god the
the
the lawyer for alex jones f and dino
right now asked for a mistrial based on
the development that happened yesterday
which was the texts that were given over
on accident or by accident
and the judge goes well i don't really
see anything that's there
in terms of that would that would
justify right
and he goes well it's attorney you know
and she's like well look i've seen one
text message that was shown yesterday
which was the one where he was like do
you see all the messages in blue whose
phone is that from and alex jones that's
from my phone and it goes do you know
where i got those text messages your
lawyer sent me two years which ended up
being three years worth of text to me
and they did not say it was protected
they did not say it was privileged
information between attorney client
um
and so he didn't say anything right he
sat there like oh i don't know what's
going on you know
so right now the lawyer has said you've
asked for a mistrial 17 times right
she's [ __ ] throwing that she's
throwing shade she's [ __ ] throwing
[ __ ] at the fan and just letting
everyone get a whiff and so now she said
you know you've asked for it 17 times i
don't see why this is any way protected
right i've only seen one thing uh i
don't know if there's actually anything
there that is protected between client
uh attorney privilege
oh and by the way i'm gonna just deny
that outright source
the moral of the story is that that that
alex jones is completely [ __ ] here
right exactly like in an attempt to save
his ass meaning the attorney's ass out
of the situation the lawyer the judge
was like yeah
no look look you guys have tried to
[ __ ] make a clown show of this whole
court and i have had the restraint
to not kick you in the [ __ ] balls
each time
and i've let you play this game i've let
you foolishly uh you know embarrass
yourself in front of everyone watching
oh she's a genius at this point it's
great because there's no way that anyone
be able to say oh this mistrial there's
precedence or there are prejudice
against alex jones because of his
behavior continue this night he's doing
that you keep being an idiot right well
here's the thing and i've said this time
and time again when these when these
idiots
have their their shovel in their hand
and they're digging their political or
their financial grave right do not take
the shovel out of their hand yeah but
frankly this judge did what she should
have done gave them a [ __ ] backhoe is
basically what she did she's like yeah
absolutely i'll i'll let you bury
yourself this is perfect you need do you
need any additional equipment do you
need it right back from this bumper
right now i've got a whole crew of
people that are willing to come and
absolutely destroy you and she's done a
marvelous job everyone's like oh she
should have slapped the hammer down and
all that but frankly al she knew alex
jones was going to do what alex jones
does and bury himself with his stupid
[ __ ] mouth yeah that is what happened
uh stick around everyone we're going to
go to a break as soon as we come back we
have dr rachel bittikover
to give us some insight into how
democracy is being saved as we speak
stick around you are not going to want
to miss doc's insights right after this
break stick around
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50 a day
you can help us help those true
americans recover from biden's socialist
reign of terror these are those trump
supporters and this is that moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only 50 a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around to the break
we got a great guess for you
gonna break down the primaries
that we just had this week
great news for democracy there's a lot
there's a lot moving the needle and not
just this alex jones rachel dr rachel
better golfer thanks for joining us how
are you rachel
i really love my my dance apparently i
have a whole dance that gabe does
yeah you know any time any time rachel
comes over
i love how like it is literally like the
hippie shuffle too
[Laughter]
i'm so excited to have you rachel
that's what we call the damn ban
audiences tony if you've never seen
these guys you know if you've ever been
to a grateful dead show or anything like
that you get get a lot of people just
breaking breaking news breaking
man
breaking news dr rachel bittikover is a
deadhead um breaking breaking news
rachel i'm so excited to have you it's
been a while since you've been on you've
been super busy and rightfully so
because we've been trying to get this
messaging out there me and you have been
talking about it for months and months
and months and i think
i think we are in a position to say
that it's starting to take hold and it's
starting to work people are paying
attention to what the republicans are
trying to take away from america which
is democracy they're paying
attention i saw i saw a statistic this
morning that they're saying that 20
percent of those ballots marked no you
will not take my bodily autonomy away in
kansas didn't mark anything else on the
ballot what do you think that means
i mean it's affirming right i mean the
reason why primaries don't generally hit
43 45 turnout is because there's no
heuristic on a ballot so people like you
and i we care enough and we know who
these people are and we'll go and pick
somebody but most of the electorates
like dude without that party label to
tell me which person to to vote for i
really don't want to deal with it you
know and so i do think that there was a
lot of excess turnout and i'm not
surprised at all that they only filled
out the one thing on the ballot that
they came there to do
don't get me wrong i would not have
wanted that to happen if the messenger
cyrus saw some activist bitching online
about
how the novo got 15 more than the
democratic whatever right and i'm like
listen dude if you want that people to
connect that no vote to democrats you
got to make that league you got to make
that connection that's right we got to
bake that in the cake and i think it's
starting this idea that republicans
really are the party that are trying to
take away your liberty they're trying to
take away your way of life i think it's
starting to bake in and that's what that
tells us because these are people who
don't want to be politically active
that's what it tells me like these
people don't want to vote for republican
or democrat like you said they really
don't want to engage in the civics the
body politic but they do not do not want
the government republicans especially
telling them they can't have their
liberty it's ridiculous to think that in
this country you're going to try to take
away my liberty just because you take
power and you think that your religion
is over our state i don't think so and i
think that's what it shows in kansas
specifically and i think it means a lot
for other states like texas georgia and
even pennsylvania and ohio how do those
races um
how do you think those races are
affected by
what we have now know in kansas that is
that is happening to the republican
party well listen i mean what happened
in kansas isn't because of kansas okay
it's because
was eviscerated and they wanted this
thing on the ballot right
so i mean yeah it was a direct question
should we amend the constitution so we
can get rid of abortion and that's kind
of a unique circumstance that allows us
it allows the messaging to kind of focus
on the issue and not on on parties or
partisan politics so much but generally
speaking when we think about wedging
abortion for these candidates that are
running in the senate governor's races
state legislature all the way down the
school board honestly
what you want to be doing is is uh
making it clear this person's a
republican the republican party is
stealing your freedom
well i think you're right i i had our
great friend uh david bender on
yesterday another great political
strategist don't tell david i said this
and i don't think he would mind you're
my favorite political strategist i'm
picking favorites here but
what you you love the f word that's what
is near and dear to my heart
no that is not true gabe knows even in
private i call dr rachel with a governor
my favorite yes that
how it is
i stick to it rachel
but um david bender uh alluded to
yesterday here in missouri we watched
eric greitens get trounced because of
his not only his record but his dumb
[ __ ] in that he actually believed
that this idea that he was gonna he was
gonna project that he was gonna kill
dissidents in his party was gonna get
people in his party to vote for him this
is really stupid [ __ ] it's the same
stuff like carrie lake is doing with
this maricopa county vote like you're
going to suppress your vote in the
general even if you win you bonehead but
i guess my david's point was this is
that what is and he made this point what
is eric schmidt who is the attorney
general in missouri what's his stand on
roe v wade right and i think that's
important what david is trying to say is
we need to get every single one of these
candidates whether it's for senate
governor legislator all the way down to
the goddamn dog catcher to tell us
because it's so important about the road
decision not exactly what their personal
feelings are about roe and abortion but
where do you stand on taking away
americans rights where do you stand on
that because i think that is the issue
i think that is yeah and you know like
interfacing with a with a politician in
an interview is one thing i care more
about the messaging strategy that gets
deployed to defeat them right and like
you know here's the thing is like it
doesn't it doesn't [ __ ] matter it
doesn't [ __ ] matter if susan collins
is tells everyone she's pro-choice but
bro voted for you know this court to
undermine roe
what matters is this the republican
party has eviscerated the right for
privacy for women and is coming after
the right to privacy for other
marginalized groups
and it doesn't matter if individual
candidate is
proclaims to be more moderate on
abortion or support the exceptions what
matters is the reality of what the
republican party has done and is doing
so every one of them should be
run against as if they personally
eviscerated roe and took away every
exception that was you know
critical at really even within their own
coalition to making it popular
so what you're saying is we should chain
this road decision to their ankles
before we throw them into the ocean of
you're out of government is that what
you're saying because i think what
you're saying is it doesn't matter what
the hell they say because they're going
to lie no matter what what we have it
didn't matter that jamie harrison never
wanted to fund the police okay what did
they do in south carolina to beat jamie
harrison they told all those white
voters down there this black dude wants
to defund the police okay so why don't
why for them i mean if we're gonna go in
this and we're in a [ __ ] war okay
keep in mind so we have to like we have
to use or neutralize these asymmetries
and that's one of our worst asymmetries
is this assumption that it has to be
technically correct for the technical
person that i'm running against when
that same quarter is never never
expected to us and so what i'm trying to
teach people is this i don't give a [ __ ]
if you're running at the state local
level i don't care if you're running for
a federal office tie your person to the
republican party and then make sure
people understand that the republican
party is a terrible stinky turd that no
one wants to touch
and she wonders why i call her my
favorite political people i mean yeah
well she was very she was very high-end
that is what we need to have i believe
that is the messaging because
so long liberals have talked over people
when we just need to sit down at the
table and talk to them gabe what says
well i was going to say to to add on to
rachel's point about how you need to tie
this directly to the the person that is
running because like obviously if you
can put a talking point to a face then
that's it right you've already
established a connection you know that
person is not good or that person is
good depending on what side you're going
for
because of xyz right it's it's
when you think of a concept or an idea
or a platform as an uh as something that
is abstract it's hard to associate but
if you can see it as a person you can
humanize it then it is very effective
and i think that is so true here where
it's like yeah you know democrats we
want to play fair we want to take the
high moral ground all that stuff but
you have to you know whether it's
speaking in hyperbole which then you
know hyperbole actually ends up being
reality right it's like they want to
marry your kids they want to do this
they want to you know make sure that
little girls have your children it's
it's gone from like that's crazy and
extreme no one would do that to within a
short period of time it's like it's
happening it's reality so when
you know whether you're technically
right or not it's like it doesn't
[ __ ] matter because at the end of the
day they're going to take that extreme
angle
and make it a reality so you might as
well just jump to that conclusion
because they're inevitably going to end
up there
and it's it's le it's it's more than
might as well if you do not do this
transition on your message you will lose
okay so
you need to do it it's not about might
as well it's about like you know
survival political survival and when the
opposition party is doing that
broad-based branding you you here's the
thing jamie harrison spent months trying
to clarify his stance and to fund the
police right so who gives a [ __ ] if
susan collins spends months trying to
clarify her stance on row i could give
two shits dude i hope she does because
it means she's on defense and that my
messaging worked
well you know speaking of being on
defense and messaging um we watched as
comedian jon stewart absolutely
destroyed not just the republican party
on this pack act but destroyed specific
republicans ted cruz in particular
and that's the kind of message that we
need when i when i watched the press
conference because we watched it live
here on the show just as well it was
right after it happened and john stewart
was in front of a microphone pointing at
the capitol and calling republicans
those [ __ ] that was the quotes
those [ __ ] he pointed and said
those words and he was talking about
republicans who were voting against this
i was like it's gonna this this is the
movement that is gonna take us to
another place and the reason why is
because the paradigm has to shift and it
has to shift away from we're always us
liberals are always defending our
strength which is there liberalism is
strength people liberalism is not
weakness authoritarianism is the easy
road that's the easy road to let one
person decide what the [ __ ] you're gonna
do or what you're not gonna do
liberalism is tough democracy is hard so
the messaging i agree with you like we
have to not let up on these idiots and
jon stewart didn't like he went
everywhere he could possibly go no doubt
and yeah and yeah
like here's the thing is like i would
say to john dude and and you can you can
look through like the comments that he
made at that pressure and then the one
yesterday at the sign you know when it
was announced that it would be signed
and you know he's like never have so
have a group of people sacrificed so
much to get so little right and he was
so frustrated because like his point
about that is that the republican
part of our country's government is
broken and not it can't even give
veteran health benefits for burn pits
what else it can't do any [ __ ] thing
right so like what i would say to john
is i know he's really tired because he
has invested so much emotional energy
and months and months and months but
like we can't have it we can't have them
let up we need that kind of outrage
every single day from our a-list people
a-less celebrities because unfortunately
most people in america don't watch any
news any politics but you know what they
do love is celebrity and it is shitty
that you want that i'm telling you hey
we should rely on people on hollywood
celebs to help save democracy but i'm
going to tell you if you want to move
people that's how you do it
well and he did it in such a selfless
way rachel like this was such a selfish
way and he and the reason why it was so
effective is because he did the exact
same thing with the first responders and
their survivor the first responder
survivors in 9 11 when congress and
republicans were doing the exact same
thing to them when they were like oh we
love our first responders and right we
always remember never forget 9 11 and
then they [ __ ] all over them yeah but he
did the same thing i think that's why
he's so effective um yeah but i i'm
trying to find a picture here here it is
i want to show you a picture here which
is one of the most beautiful things to
come out of this whole thing
here is jon stewart standing there and i
and and and i i agree with you that the
celebrity isn't as important as the
messaging and the reason why it's that
selfless message from jon stewart
because he wasn't there to talk about
him he wasn't there to sell his message
it was wrong he was authentic yeah
that's right because it truly is a
passion of john's that that these
veterans get the money because he is
sick and tired of the government in
general we the people us we're the
government yeah not giving not oh [ __ ]
tony i mean when i say listen we need
celebrities to get involved the last
[ __ ] thing i need is like you know
yes we can videos okay those are all
fine and dandy but that is not what i
mean and we you we have a huge asset in
hollywood that we've never utilized
properly in terms of moving and shaping
public opinion and this is an all hands
on deck moment so if you happen to be an
a-list liberty and i know they all
listen to tony michaels and gabe
sanchez's podcast
get angry for democracy and start to to
use your
huge following i mean irt and i hit 140
000. jon stewart hits like what i don't
know 10 million so there's no comparison
and and so it's that celebrity audience
size they have what we need access to
people that avoid politics right and
they can pass that messaging on to
people and have that strategic outrage
you coined that phrase here on this show
i believe strategic outrage and we have
pounded that drum and pounded that drum
and pounded that drum because i think
it's so appropriate and that's exactly
what jon stewart did he was pulling over
on the side it reminded me like when
you've come on the show and you're in
your truck like
with your cell phone jon stewart pulled
over on the side of the road and he is
holding his cell phone to do an
interview with newsmax and fox news the
whole day from from morning till night
was probably on the same side of the
road to get home because of that dude
yeah
from dca and it should take like you
know
about three and a half if the traffic's
okay
but that's how that's how you know that
it was selfless though is because he was
begging fox news to get in front of
those viewers because he john john knows
something about media and and the reason
why he does is because he's he's always
been so brilliant at it with the daily
show but he's so brilliant with media he
knew that the fox news viewers who those
people are if they actually got just a
whiff of the truth of this pact act that
they would hold these
republican senators their senators
accountable like ted cruz and ron
johnson and all these despicable vile
pieces of [ __ ] who decided to tuck tail
and run on this because mansion did a
deal with schumer like that's literally
what it's such a strategically
unfortunate it's rare that republicans
make unforced errors so when they do we
should capitalize on them and it was an
unforced era to do this i mean there's
absolutely no benefit politically for
them to do this and because we're
starting to turn this titanic and have
the infrastructure in place to amplify
events like jon stewart too it really is
it hurt them like it we made
reputational and brand like movement we
gained ground not just the cycle but
just broadly speaking because the
republican party [ __ ] on our burn
right and
and we didn't let them do it in a vacuum
well that's right because gabe we talked
to david bender yesterday about the same
thing about organizing
and it it feels like almost the january
6 select committee and some of that
organizing behind the select committee
and the messaging that was there it
feels like that apparatus is almost um
part of the machine now like like it has
caused the democrats to go oh you know
what if we just get organized and we
just pop a message and everyone
amplifies that message then everyone
will hear it and we talked about what
that with david bender yesterday gabe
yeah right now
however i'm sorry you said no no i was
just gonna say yeah i mean like it's you
know it's what we've been saying you
know during this whole conversation
right now which is like you know
identify especially identifying a strong
powerful voice with a large you know
base like someone like jon stewart who
is you know outside of being a comedian
and someone who's a celebrity like he's
just a normal person he's not a
politician right he entered politics
through comedy
and has made his his career that way
and uh you look at this and you're like
well if everyone
can follow
and echo exactly what he is saying write
that outrage and be like yeah i'm also
[ __ ] pissed off this is nuts right
can echo the same thing that he's saying
which is again you know outside of being
a celebrity he's just
another person
uh then it can be very effective right
you know getting on that box and saying
this is what we're gonna talk about and
everyone says okay this is what we're
gonna talk about and just just you know
not too long ago we were talking about
associating with
uh with um talking points or like
platforms with people and jon stewart
did a great job you know hitting to me
hitting ted cruz for whatever dumb
reason these people wanted to double
down and every time
jon stewart went on the air he was like
i've asked them again and again and
again and i will ask you guys
find the part in the bill that was
changed no one can do it because it
wasn't
yes
he totally got the matrix right apart
with that right
well and the other thing too rachel back
to this january select machine because
you're talking about this amp of
amplification machine do you believe
that that because it's
i don't think january 6 select committee
and the evidence that happened on the
coup d'etat attempt the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup as i call it um i believe
that's tied directly to row that's the
overturning row is part of the coup
attempt they are attempting a coup that
is the whole point they're trying to
take away your liberty that is part of
the coup so do you do you think that um
democrats really pushing behind where
they got a television producer to
produce the the actual event or the the
the hearings the season one as it were
but do you think
organizing and developing behind that
machine
will help democrats in the midterms and
even going forward that hey
if we do organize if we do stick
together on these issues and we do stick
together on this messaging we can beat
these son of a [ __ ] all day long easy
easy
i mean at the end of the day what i sell
is pretty it's a pretty um harsh
medicine
but but what but what i'm promising
people is like look if we make these
changes right there's more we will
[ __ ] dominate these people
electorally and it will take some time
but we we will i mean they they
the goal is to
like if that the reason the republican
party has continued to get worse and
worse and now it's like carrie lake's
party
is because there's been no
accountability at the ballot box for
them we must make them pay electorally
there's only one check that we can serve
the republican party that they give a
[ __ ] about and that is power and seats
right so we can make them pay
electorally in the long term we would
force them to reassess whether they
really should just abandon all um
caution and go full fascist
well and and maybe maybe they either
create a different because we do have a
two-party system and we've had this
[ __ ] stupid thing with andrew yang
which i'm not even gonna get into it's
not even worth talking about really
because we have a two-party system not a
three-party system yeah don't talk about
andrew gang [ __ ] that right
[ __ ] [ __ ] him [ __ ] him twice
but the point is the point is this that
i'm trying to make is that that it's
just
we have a two-party system and it is the
system of government and and it is our
constitutional republic the problem that
we really have is we don't have two
parties interested in that republic and
that's the strain that we have when you
have carrie lake which you brought up
gary lake and [ __ ] lunatic
she is literally this morning i think
still
talking about how the election she might
win
was rigged
by who i i tried to say this in the
first three minutes like why would if
democrats i mean rachel i know if you
were gonna rig it you would rig it for
the candidate who got like two percent
in the poll i would never let someone
who got 30 in a poll
to to be the nominee if i was gonna rig
it so
she's not saying democrats are rigging
it she has to be saying that republicans
are rigging so which is it is it
democrats or evil you know blood second
cabal that want to rig elections with
chavez voting machines or is it the
republicans she can't decide
do you i i think this is very
detrimental to their party what they're
doing i think it's actually suppressed
because like who she's bitching about is
the mccain republicans and there's only
one place in the nation other than the
northeast which has this really weird
political um it's much heavier on
independence and more pure independence
than leaners so it's different up there
um but in any case like like with her
with arizona there's there are michigan
or um mccain republicans in arizona we
know for sure and this is i was pushed
back about the lincoln project people oh
i didn't do anything well actually
arizona did quite a bit because there is
this this little excess part of the part
it's nothing major guys but in an
election that could come down to one
point it is incredibly important so
let's just hope that carrie lake
does everything she can to stoke the ire
of the of the small but still important
mccain republicans in arizona because it
will be those people who decide whether
they have a fascist or not at the end of
the day when we get down to it
eyes they're also i mean they also you
know uh you know rusty bowers right the
the arizona rep who
who came forward and talked about his
experience with rudy giuliani saying we
don't have evidence we've got theories
right and the whole exchange with with
donald trump like
her argument again is saying that
those votes were totally fair and valid
so he he was primaried out
but if i lose it's not fair you know
it is yeah it's just insane you know
again because
tony and i talked about this yesterday
it's like you have dominion
and or you know in and she's complaining
about 2020 and she's like it wasn't fair
then but nothing has changed between
then and now between these systems if
anything they're probably more secure
and now she's saying oh
if i lose it's it is definitely rigged
but if i win
all is right in the world well let's
let's lay out
that
let's let's lay out the facts here in
arizona it's the republicans who have
had charge of these machines in these in
these votes so if they didn't fix it
where the [ __ ] are they obviously i
would not want someone in charge who
knew there was election front and did
nothing about it right i definitely
wouldn't want those people in charge so
what is carrie lake saying here i want
to move to one more race that a lot of
people are bitching about and i think
it's a great thing that democrats did i
actually think they hit the nail on the
head here i think they should be doing
everything they can to win these races
even if they have to support it even if
they support a candidate like gibbs in
michigan against a uh an anti-trump or
as they call him where he voted to
impeach donald trump mayor and you're
like why would you want to get rid of
that republican we want to get rid of
all of them let's be clear of that let's
be clear that we want to smoke out every
single one of them in our government
because we never know when where this
fashion fascism is going to seep in and
the fact the fact that they democrats
looked at this and and saw the
investment and i think it was like four
or five hundred grand i think is what
the number was and and this is i think
very few races that they picked out this
is the high profile one that they did
this in where they actually participated
in the republican primary and um it i
don't know if it pulled him over the
line or not but he did win that the the
candidate that the democrats back
because they think they can beat him
easier than mayor um it's not a thing
it's a fact okay we don't think we can
beat this dude easier than mayor it is a
fact that we can beat him easier than
mayor and we're in a situation where it
will take an absolute divine
intervention for us to hit 218 in the
house of representatives and to save the
house of representatives majority from
what the republican party intends to do
with it which is to turn it into a [ __ ]
show right so we um you know normally in
normal times do i think it's good to get
involved in primaries and elevate crazy
people that you know whatever no i don't
i don't think so this is not normal
times
right well and i think you know when
we're in these times of
of not of abnormal i think you're right
we have to do abnormal things and like
you said earlier these republicans do
this [ __ ] all the time they do this same
[ __ ] all the time where they
do their damnedest to get the democrat
on the ballot that they want because
they know they can beat them they do
this all
all the time and for and for anyone
anyone to shake their finger at
democrats to participate in the fight of
democracy because it's a shake all damn
day i don't give a [ __ ] dude honestly
we'll give them another finger yeah my
job is to keep america from slipping
into a fascist hellhole and in in
pursuit of that goal i'm gonna be
straight with everybody i deal in lead
right well and and i think um i think it
was adam parkamenko that made the point
on a cnn interview he said look
democrats are choosing selectively these
races because what you said we know we
can beat this candidate and we know it's
an investment that is worth it in the
long run for democracy this isn't a
choice of anti-democracy and i actually
called out adam kenzinger um the other
day because he went and he went on a
tirade saying i don't want to hear it
from democrats that they're
pro-democracy but they're supporting
this candidate they're not supporting
that candidate adam and that bullside
[ __ ] is exactly why i even though he's
doing the great thing of being on the
select committee you still have to know
who these republicans are you have to
understand who these are this is not a
both sides issue there's not a both
sides i've been training people to you
know to take criticism like that and
understand it's going to come if you
make moves like investing to you know uh
replace a moderate republican with a nut
right um you're going to get all kinds
of criticism but you know at the end of
the day the people who are enacting
these strategies who that we don't
people don't have a choice we people who
are making decisions right now as to
what to do and for me personally that's
tapping into fear
and threat emotions to improve turnout
and to push independent voters away from
republicans but in this case it was you
know somebody
spending to elevate a primary candidate
the stock we're doing is only being done
under the recognition that we're all
hands on deck take out every stop if we
don't hold congress here we may never
see a free and fair election in 2024 and
that may be the last free and fair
election we do see so you know at this
point thinking about long-term
consequences is not you have to you have
to balance stuff right and some and when
things are good long-term consequences
matter a lot okay
but when things have been ignored and
left this far because by the way it is
our failure to really position ourselves
and to make these changes ten years ago
that have left us in the position where
we are literally looking at fascism
overtaking the american government so
like it's i would argue to people we've
waited way too long to do [ __ ] like this
right i i agree with you um and we're
glad to have you in the fight i'm so
glad you are on our side not on their
side because you would be kicking our
ass
if you were so i'm glad you're out there
you're kicking ass and taking names
thank you rachel for everything
apparently making 800 000 a day guys i
mean [ __ ] you guys are in the wrong
business you should turn into you know
alex jones and [ __ ] get a million i
mean i've got some i've got some herbal
pills i can hawk on the show yeah well
rachel rachel give us give us your plug
for your herbal your herbal supplements
no i'm just kidding everyone go follow
everyone go follow dr rachel bittikov or
on twitter at rachel biddikoffer please
follow pay attention to her messaging
she tweets it every day all day you can
see the messaging right there
right there on her twitter page
uh rachel the other thing to do is
yeah take the advice take the advice
yeah well you sent me a link here
recently too of some stuff that's coming
or or soon can you tell us about that
some of the messaging that's there
i'm sorry i sent you what
some kind of packet it was like it was
like uh some stuff some some messaging
things
is it
i i don't know i'm not 100 sure
in any case yes i mean i what i put out
on twitter i put out for a reason i want
people to take the ideas the concepts
hell even literally the phrase
and take it from me steal it from me and
use it for your own purposes i don't
care because at the end of the day what
we will take all hands on deck and um
i'm much more concerned with getting as
much uh cacophony in our messaging as
much spread and volume as possible than
i am about credit ever
i'm so glad you came back we have to
have you back more often really so we
need to find time in your schedule to
talk about this stuff because i think
it's very important um thank you very
very much rachel for joining us dr
rachel bittikov for everybody stick
around we will be right back with more
[ __ ] list roundup right after this thank
you rachel have a good one
see ya
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
i've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babble mag
edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon i was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that i'm struggling with i
chose battle mag edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now i can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new maga skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast doctor rachel
bittikoffer dropping the knowledge
helping you
get out there and save your democracy
go follow rachel and rachel bittikoffer
i'm serious
she tweets all the time mm-hmm and tells
us exactly how we are supposed to save
our she doesn't hold back and i
appreciate it it's like given like
carpet bombing boom boom messaging
messaging message in real time too like
they [ __ ] these fascist move in
rachel bittikoffer has that has that
messaging that you need right there on
twitter i always uh i i have her on
notification and i rely on what she says
like what is what is rachel dr rachel
bittikoffer saying about this specific
topic you can go to her twitter page and
you can almost no matter the time of day
i don't think she sleeps i don't know
how she does it no no she doesn't rachel
and i are actually working on something
are you right now yeah yeah i heard i
heard that i got a video i got a little
video coming got some vids huh what what
the is there any preview about this vid
or i don't i can't you know i don't want
to still you i don't want to spill the
beans man is it is it happening in this
underground bunker that you're building
there is that what it is it is done in
secret i want everyone to know that the
bone hint of the weak pole is out the
bone head of the weak pole is out and
look who is that i'm not going to show
the result i don't want to no you can't
show the results
but look who is at the top
of
the poll alex jones um i'll i'll admit
it i don't want to sway the votes but
i'm going to cheat here i voted for alex
jones i think we all collectively voted
for
holy [ __ ]
i can't even i can't i i just i want to
talk about alex jones so much and i know
because it will stop using it
still we still have to i think i know
who the dm is this week but i need to
figure out who the ac is so if in the
comments people want to chime in who
they think the alpha cuck should be
throw that in there right we've already
got alex jones rand paul and ted cruz
running i've got a certain someone in
mind he's a a a gentleman
uh who has been in the news this week
um
i don't want to reveal who it is almost
always always the alpha cuck's a dude
that's gotta say something but the dm is
a dude this week the alpha cuck who is
it who is it
let us know you tell us who you think
should be the alpha cuck and and the
dishonorable mention but oh yeah it
sounds like you've chosen i
think you're the local election official
here at the michaels but i've got i
think i think most people will agree
with the candidate that i have chosen
for the dishonorable mention
well we'll have to see who who it is
everyone get down in there and
say who you want the alpha guk to be but
we also had rand paul and ted cruz on
this so i'm excited about tomorrow about
the breakdown of bonehead of the week
don't miss it tomorrow in the second
hour of the tony michaels podcast bone
end of the week uh so stick around and
for that also go over you can you can
you can vote right here on youtube if
you subscribe you go to the community
tab just go to the community tab and you
can vote for bone end of the week i hear
on youtube i was a little late putting
that poll out on youtube that's my
responsibility it's fine
i was really holding back i was i was
but the but i i put the poll the polls
are open now not just on youtube but
also on twitter so go to tony michael's
pod you can vote for bonehead of the
week over there and don't forget to
download
bonehead a week gabe did you know we put
bonehead of the week on all the
directories on on sunday bone end of the
week it's our favorite segment
do you say on sunday on sun sunday
sunday sunday sunday that means we have
seven seven days a week seven days a
week we got a best of we got a best of
on saturday that we that we put up
there that you can listen to the best of
i bet
and i i'm i you know both end of the
week it's always on sunday so i can
never put that in the best of right
right right now yeah but i always i
always like the interviews and the best
of so i bet i bet i bet our favorite
political strategist rachel bittikoffer
and very close second david bender works
in
nothing against david both both great
interviews and every time we have them
on the show they are you know one
they're just amazing people and two they
have such great insight onto what's
going on and also just an idea of kind
of
where things are headed and what we can
do to make sure that we don't fall into
this crazy fascist
you know [ __ ] wet dream of
republicans right well and they both
bring
political strategies from different
perspectives right dr raider rachel
bittikoffer really breaks it down to
simple bare bones raw
i always go back to the justice bat that
eric hershman has behind him but it
feels like
dr rachel bittikoffer carries around a
messaging and opposes say judging judge
justice it says messaging and she's
carrying that bat around and david
bender has a little bit different
perspective he's looking at it from a
historical perspective right and and how
things have changed over time in the
history of the political strategy you
know what i think would be very
interesting to get and we've had them on
air at the same time during the select
hearings right which was like magic like
fireworks and magic i bet i bet the
audience would love to have uh david
bender and rachel bittikoffer sit down
together
um to to to have a conversation about
political strategy maybe we should make
that happen sometime uh before this
midterm yeah i think that would be good
yeah before well maybe before the next
uh because we've got about a month or so
before
we've got the next because the date
hasn't been announced but the next
january 6th yeah the season 2 premiere
that's a good you know i think it might
be might be good to have them on before
and just talk about kind of what the
expectations are who we think it's gonna
be brought in we've got a ton of new you
know evidence and witnesses coming
forward you know just the alex jones
text itself like it feels like a goddamn
rosetta stone right back
what is going on with january 6 and what
happened right so god damn i can't stop
thinking about this alex jones stager
rhone he's gonna go broke he's
completely [ __ ] like it's just endless
with this guy this week has been has
been uh
has been amazing it's been a great week
it really has been i'm like i'm excited
about this week and it feels like the
energy out there is changing like people
are like wow if we really do just
organize and we get together and we stop
talking about issues that we're against
each other or we don't exactly agree on
the exact amount or the number or where
the where the line is drawn but we agree
on the idea of i don't know democracy
that we can band together and we can
[ __ ] crush these fascists and get to
a point to where if they want to have a
party that is for democracy fine but if
you do not we are not going to allow you
to have the reins of government we're
just not going to let you do it um i
wanted to go to the alex jones um thread
here and see if there's any
new video coming out of um
coming out of uh the
the hearing this is 15 minutes ago ron
has something posted here now lawyers
claim plankton via uh lawyers violated
the client privilege this is the video
we already watched i believe yeah well
this might be i don't know if it's uh
i mean you can play it it might be
either i don't know if that goes before
or after the moment
that his his jud or his uh attorney oh
yes yes because because when we watched
it before alex jones attorney was
standing up now again i wanna i wanna
tell the audience
the reason why
it's hard to hear the alex jones child
and i think i think a lot of people like
a lot of production um
companies missed this like they were all
over the herd depth trial and they had
everything miked perfect the courtroom
is mike for this drama this courtroom is
not miked for that type of drama well i
don't think they expected right this
type of drama to come out no and so i
mean like look they've got a mic
they've got one mic in the back i what
they're doing right now is they're
trying to capture any sound from around
the area because you've got a mic that's
up if you were to approach the bench
there's another mic next to it you've
got a mic to uh mike at the
the defense you've got a mic at the uh
the prosecutor you got a mic in the
middle by where the stand here is you
gotta probably a mic obviously for the
judge and the the witness stand
um
but it's not i mean there are moments
when they talk and you still can't quite
catch it you know right because they
don't have it miked in a way
that is for drama and production like we
would think of it's more just the record
because these are boom mics and boom
mics like the way that they work is like
if you're far away then you're gonna get
you know it's gonna if i move my mic
it's gonna sound like it's further away
and it's gonna be hard to capture right
as opposed to like you're right up
against the mic here and you can hear me
perfectly so you know if it was
other other ways to do it would be you
would hang you see it in different types
of performances uh on stage you'll have
hanging mics that are on on wires that
come down
and those actual because the way that
you talk when you're talking you're you
know going out this way and these boom
mics are trying to angle them all in the
right way and it doesn't always work
that well so having you know basically
dangling mics for this would have been
the way that i would have probably mic
this uh this courtroom other than you
put a lapel mic on someone but right but
this is well and and normally you'd have
like the judge would have a lapel mic so
everything they could see the lawyers
might have lapel mics that they can turn
on and off but a lot of times there's a
mic in front of them that they can turn
on and off that will give them a good
sound in between and also at the podium
you notice the podium isn't even i mean
it's miked
but normally normally in a trial where
they would be broadcasting they'd have
the actual podium mic so they have this
mic for record not for drama and
broadcasting and that's one of the
troubles that we're having with sound
here when you see these clips so you
just want to tell the audience like
that's kind of the background of this
because even yesterday when i when i
made that clip for this
curvier defamation i had to go through
and actually edit the audio to make the
sound levels
as equal as i could you know and when
you do that you're bringing up the gain
so you're hearing the basically the room
noise so it's like
right right you're you're you know
trying to fix it is a bit of a hassle if
you can't get it right the first time
and i posted a clip um when the judge uh
chastised alex jones for lying on the
stand twice and told him not to do it
again um i posted that clip it got
millions of views because it was so
[ __ ] hilarious for him to her to
shake your finger now what i did with
that clip is i zoomed in on it and i
tried to adjust the volume but just what
you're saying because she was sitting so
far away from the mic that was on that
audio because it was just a room mic it
wasn't actually these microphones
it was a room mic that was picking up
her sound and i tried to turn it up but
you couldn't hear her because all that
all that static was there so i zoomed in
i made the best i could for people to
turn it up to hear it and everyone could
hear it but um let's listen to what this
video shows here
it appears after alex jones attorneys
have made their plea to mistral
what's interesting to me is this is not
the first time
that materials like this have been
inadvertently produced in this case as
you may remember from prior hearings mr
barnes inadvertently produced materials
now in that case some of that
information ended up coming out they
ended up letting me keep some of it and
we ended up talking about it but there
were a german community kind of
excuse me attorney-client communications
in there which you don't know about
which i do
which they did follow 193.3 and they did
identify those by eight stage numbers
that here is the privilege and when that
happened i promptly returned them and
destroyed all my columns
so basically what the alex jones
attorney in simple form what out at what
i'm getting i'm no lawyer but from what
i know about the attorney prior client
privilege that we've talked to about
karen and nipollo um
an extent and popock an extent here on
the tony michaels podcast it appears
what is what what the planktive the
sandy hook attorney is saying is hey
they followed attorney client privilege
we filed the protocol and this is not
what that is they've done it in the past
right and they asked if we could destroy
it and we said yes send it back we sent
it back and i destroyed my local copies
because they said it was attorney client
privilege which means that nobody other
than the attorney and client can have
access or see those things or at least
use those things if they so choose right
i can't just like throw that out on the
[ __ ] you know other thing and then
they would say oh that's attorney-client
privilege we've already established it
and the judge would have to say strike
it from the record the jury which i
always find interesting when you're like
hey jury disregard what you just heard
which as a human you cannot disregard
what you just heard the game
the last six months disregard everything
i said yeah just forget anything i've
ever said like you know if they had a
men in black like you know like little
flash totally but whenever i hear a
judge say jury disregard what you just
heard you're like
but i can't i literally cannot forget
that it's gonna influence what i what i
make my decision on you know in terms of
the verdict but yeah
he's trying to you know he's trying to
show that they know they are they are
competent enough to follow this protocol
and they told us before to do it and we
did it and this time
even when they were notified about it
they didn't do anything they didn't say
was protected they didn't say was client
attorney privilege they just said
uh whatever
and now it's like well that's what you
guys decided so that's not our fault we
followed we followed the procedure
here's another 23 seconds from this uh
from this law and crime youtube channel
here um from the uh trial um this is the
part where you were talking earlier
about stager rhone let's listen is all
of the stuff in there he cannot now come
into court and claim 2.3 gigabytes of
phone material blanket designation of
confidentiality the protective order
prohibited you must identify
specifically the documents that are and
and things like like mr jones and his
intimate messages with roger stone are
not confidential they're not traits
none of them
there's been no protection ever asserted
over these documents
so that was strategic it was that's
right it appears to me that this
attorney knows that this evidence that
he has is far more reaching to destroy
alex jones yeah than just in this court
right and even you know in the judge you
know the judge uh hearing hearing that
right she has to decide like oh can you
say those things you know like
is it is it at all relevant and it's not
because this is sandy hook and that's
roger stone so roger stones can be
brought into this whole defamation trial
like that is unrelated so he's going to
drop that nugget because he knows people
are going to talk about it and he knows
that you know the the next time we'll
probably hear about it is during the
january 6 committee so he has to
establish that there is there is some
meaty [ __ ] in here
that they need to get a hold of dude
meaty meaty [ __ ] intimate i'm sorry i'm
sorry the phrasing of what i said
seditious sexting baby nasty bastard oh
bringing up bringing up meaty text
messages when when stager rhone and alex
jones are are intimately texting and you
throw out the words i don't know like
the fact that he said intimate intimate
right
that right i i mean private but intimate
like right think about this he's being
very specific yeah yeah his attorney is
using every word he has it all written
out in front of him he's like i will
deliberately say this because i know
people will talk about i mean there's
already articles that are covering this
whole intimate text everyone's like what
the [ __ ] are these intimate texts right
it again like this guy is taking a
[ __ ] cue
from the january 6 committee and how
they're producing that tv show and he's
like ooh people only care about the
juicy contents you know if it's some
moment where you know i get you caught
in a in a lie and and purge yourself
great if i can reveal some of these
texts that aren't privileged information
or relevant to this case but people are
going to want to know about it because
of your behavior and actions around
something like i don't know staging a
coup
people are going to people are going to
[ __ ] bite especially the january 6
select committee with their little
subpoenas they're going to pay attention
right because i think that's the other
thing that he's doing right is like he
knows that this trial is going to
destroy alex jones financially that's
the whole point of it the whole point of
this trial is to determine the amount of
money that he has to pay in damages to
the people that he is found guilty of
defaming
already this is just just the process of
figuring out what that amount looks like
now
this attorney understands that the
evidence in this in in this
slog of
text messages
rather they're meaty messages with star
jarone or not or whatever they're about
he knows that this evidence is going to
be interesting that someone at the
january 6 select committee and the
department of justice is going to be
interested in he probably doesn't know
the extent of it because
you have to remember like even if you
looked at your own text messages to
someone that you knew and you were
talking about something specific
it would be really hard from an outsider
to really determine what the hell they
were talking about anyways normally
you know people kind of talk in code and
text messages anyway it's not really
code but right you know you have
personal relationships with someone
you're going to talk in a certain
language with them in a text message
thread and not only that
you're also
you know that alex jones and roger stone
are [ __ ] talking in code anyways yeah
right like anyways they're talking
anything and they might have and here's
the thing they might have been not
talking in code at that certain point
and then they switched over and the
other part and it doesn't matter because
they got all of it exactly you've got
three years this is well before january
6th right you've got trump still in
office as we prepare for the election
like this is everything from you know
two three years ago we're talking 2019
august of 2019
leading into the pandemic and everything
that led you know that followed during
the summer leading into the election in
in the fall
leading into january 6 like all of that
stuff
is on record and they have it you know
you know so i'm also surprised that
nobody used a [ __ ] burner in this
situation well right
they're not that smart they really
aren't i mean
they think they can get away with
anything that's right that's really
their downfall here that's the reason
why alex jones is sitting in the
position that he's in um i forgot to
bring this up to retro i really wanted
to ask her about this maybe we'll bring
her on next week and ask about this
they're having another [ __ ] seat pack
they have them all the time man jesus
christ like this is
they have cpacs more than you stream
soda this is ridiculous it's crazy
it's crazy they might be they might be
addicted dude i think so well here's the
thing is i'm wondering why the hell we
don't have our own seat backs like why
don't we like you know we were talking
to rachel about like you know messaging
and and really coming at the fight with
them
we should have our own circuses every
[ __ ] week we should have these big
people people were asking me you know
after matt gates said that stuff about
you know just the misogynistic fat
phobia comments he made during his
speech people were like asking me did
the democrats have this kind of thing
and the thing we don't we don't we have
uh we have one major one you know when
it comes to like we've got the delegates
and the dnc we might have another one
going on but yeah
they always have these
they always have these stupid things
where they invite all kinds of academics
there and [ __ ] right you know it's not a
circus yeah it's not they intentionally
make it not a circus which that's the
point it the circus works like
we should do our own little circus
every now and again to get our people
riled up
yeah i mean especially if you want if
you want people to
pay attention and listen right like i'm
not gonna sit through uh hours of some
person giving a relatively monotone
speech about the economy or whatever
like
you know the speech might be
pointless
but if it's engaging then you can get
people to clip it and share it and get
people to talk about just not even the
the speech or things that were given but
you can talk about the event right like
if this is really a branding messaging
thing
then there should be something
on the democratic side to allow
for us to say hey we got this event
coming up and we're going to have these
speakers it's going to be young voices
in the democratic party people who are
coming up who are who are big uh big
time uh big names
um established names um new voices all
these things like if you can you have an
event like that
where you can build a messaging
a consistent cohesive messaging
within a wide range of demographics
it's like why wouldn't you do that right
but the only major ones that we have are
one we're like hey okay we delegates
vote for this candidate you know that's
pretty much it well again i think it
goes back to we got to create a circus
around these other clowns and just and
and just make it to where we can get
engaged we can get people excited about
democracy and not not about this the
line item bills because that's the
shittiest thing is they have all these
events where they're talking about line
items and bills and all that [ __ ] and
like look you got to control the
government to a certain extent before
you can really
really get in a situation where you can
say yeah
that that is the policy that we can get
around but you can't have that policy if
you don't actually govern and to govern
you have to do elections you have to
politicize things you have to and that
is what is working right it's working we
are politicizing the [ __ ] out of it
and it's working and we will politicize
the [ __ ] out of it here every single
weekday monday through friday two full
hours yeah youtube twitter twitch and
simon casting from the midas touch
facebook page join us every single day
and look if you miss it it's okay you
can subscribe to the youtube channel and
you can watch the replay you can watch
the replay there don't forget to go vote
for bonehead of the week
tomorrow's friday gabe and then the
second hours bonehead of the week until
tomorrow noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific
surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking